magnus carlsen is through with that win
and huge congratulations magnus wow what
an ending
uh yeah thank you thank you very much um
[Music]
how are you feeling after getting
through that's the most important
thing but obviously it's a massive
relief
so how much were you aware of sort of
the situation with tie breaks and
everything with lavon with napogniachi
mom jaro
before this last round
no i i was aware that i would very very
likely be out with uh
the draw
i i was following the other games uh a
bit
but um yeah
there was only only so much that i can
do um
fortunately i managed to pull it off uh
myself and then but it was
nerve-wracking maybe uh david and
yourself
if we bring up the analysis board can
just take us through sort of the
highlights for you
in this game dave magnus when when you
won it
yeah so magnus do you think there were
any critical moments where you you
mentioned getting nervous
were there any moments you think there
might be a turnaround or that your
chances might have been
reduced in this game yeah i think i was
much much better i mean i was a bit
better after i went
b5 and after he he goes for g5 i think
i'm almost uh almost winning
um but
i don't know i think i missed
probably missed a moment to go g3
earlier on
um because i was playing a bit too
quickly there and then i allowed this d5
thing which
um probably wasn't was
necessary uh and i after that i sort of
just
uh decided that i'd had
enough of this and i just wanted uh
i just wanted some clarity
uh so i yes so i
just sacked the exchange and
i i thought i thought i'm much
better um but yeah then he
he found some more resources and then
the queen ending should be
should be drawn but i don't know what he
was thinking with the with the pawn
ending but
good for me yeah we saw the reaction on
your face when he offered that trade of
queens later on
uh yeah
it was a strange situation in the sense
because he had
he had nothing to um to play for in
this game while i had everything so
maybe
at the end he thought okay this ending
is difficult
i don't want to suffer let's see if the
queen and now if the pawn ending is a
drawn
but obviously it's not now mine is
uh to sum up the preliminaries in this
super strong tournament one of the
strongest tournaments in history
how have you felt during these three
days
so the first day was was really really
bad
and uh the second was
a lot better but a really really poor
last game
uh and today was just nerves
like i felt really really uneasy after
after losing the last game yesterday um
and
so i i never could find my my rhythm
at all today um and yeah i'm just happy
to
happy to survive and uh you end up in
sixth place that means you're gonna
face third place hikaru nakamura in the
quotient finals the repetition of the
final from
the last tournament how do you feel
about that i guess it's not ideal for
either of us but it's uh
it's a lot better than than being out
fantastic magnus huge congratulations on
a fantastic ending of today and good
luck tomorrow
thank you thanks for joining us